Good morning Hank; it’s Wednesday. That’s
not a green-screen, I’m really in Amsterdam.
So Hank I’m here in Amsterdam for two months
finishing my new book. The reason I’m in
Amsterdam will become obvious when you read
the book. Also the Yeti needs to be in Europe
because she’s working on the U.F. pavilion
for the Venice Biennale, very fancy. And so
every body has a reason to be here – say
“Hello” to the tram – except for Henry,
but, you know, he’s portable.
By the way just to orient you, we’re going
to the flower market.
Right Hank, so back in the early sixteen-hundreds,
when tulips first came to Holland, they were
prized for the richness of their color. But
there were these multi-coloured ones that
were particularly beloved. So most tulips
look like the tulips you’re used to seeing,
like these. But there were these rare and
fragile and sickly looking bulbs that made
beautiful tulips, like the Viceroy. More on
him in a second.
Right, so, throughout the first half of the
1630s – don’t worry, this is not going
to hit me – the price of tulips rose pretty
steadily, and by the winter of 1636, Hank,
the Dutch had become total tulip maniacs.
Particularly for those sickly-looking bulbs
that made brilliant flowers, like the aforementioned
Viceroy. For the amount of money a single
Viceroy bulb cost in 1637 you could have bought
all of this. I mean, Hank, forget the rye
and the fat oxen. I think I could live happily
ever after with just a suit of clothes, a
complete bed, and 4000 pounds of butter. That
comment probably didn’t make sense to the
people standing behind me. And then in 1637,
pretty much all at once, the market for tulip
bulbs completely collapsed, falling like 99%
in two months. It was one of the first great
bubbles of capitalism, Hank, but that’s
not what fascinates me, here’s what fascinates
me.
Those fragile-looking bulbs that made brilliant
flowers like the Viceroy, it turns out they
were sick with a virus called the tulip mosaic
virus. They’ve all long since died out,
and while we can look at paintings, we will
never know quite what it felt like to see
the Viceroy. I first heard of tulip mania
in Atlas by Katrina Vandenberg, this brilliant
book of poems that has shaped my think a lot
while writing this new book. Here’s how
she put it, "Aren’t you sorry you will never
see a tulip that would make you offer all
you own for the layered, translucent promise
in its brown paper wrapper?"
Hank, I’ll see you on Friday.